Brazilian television networks aired
these images of Neymar being delivered
to a hospital a harsh blow to the semo
cells hopes of winning the World Cup at
home as the super star striker fell to
the ground it was immediately clear that
the injury was serious condolences
poured in from all over the world
including from his rivals Germany's
mesut özil voiced his sorrow and hope
for a quick recovery Argentine striker
Lionel Messi expressed hope that his
friend and Barcelona teammate would soon
be back on the pitch Brazil fans were
visibly saddened by Neymar's injury and
expressed outrage that the referee
allowed plane to continue Oh chill dunk
that should have been a red card it was
a brutal foul and I should come even
think she got 20 too much thinks it out
rough play is fine but it has to be fair
fouling from behind is the large
communalism islip budge accommodation is
no replacement for NEMA everyone put
their faith in him what happens now that
copper to the moon tava Kofi Annan a
little yoga and that means that Brazil
will have to carry on without the man
considered to be its best hope for
hoisting a record sixth World Cup trophy